en toute franchise tout croche et les
yeux dans les yeux non bon impossible la
garde peut-être cyril je vous demande de
répondre sans détour
est-ce que
pendant que vous étiez en couple vous
avez eu des pensées impures pour une
autre femme où tout être vivant
donc je sais pas pour vous mais moi je
suis choqué j'adore la question
sahraouie alors elle une réponse ça
alors je vais vous dire oui je vais je
vais revenir vers vous ça démarre très
fort mais un gars pas quel jour et je
répondrai hockey avant avant avant la
fin de la course à la médaille
cyril est ce que tu as déjà eu une
aventure
c'est déjà lui aussi dit moi sur le
thème de l'amour
allez est-ce que tu es déjà eu une
aventure avec une fan de l'émission
non
franchement là les montalembert le fait
le seul qui est monté à l'envers et la
côte elle a dit raymond tu veux dire va
faire on va faire dans le désarroi je
vais poser c'est sur le thème fait ce
qu'on veut cool bazire m ont fait le
plein alors alors cette séquence est
complètement proposer un jeu sachez le
une question vous pouvez sauter géant
que vous pouvez aller d'accord hashtag
baba détecteur si vous voulez poser des
questions à l'est par oui ou par non
est ce que c'est vrai que vous êtes en
contact très avancé avec la chaîne w9
pour l'année prochaine oui ou non on la
franchit il m'a bouffé une patrie de
mecs de lever 9
vraiment je vais quitter ses 8 points et
sur w9 groupe m6 bon ben ça c'est
derrière question sa propre m6
mais là non avancé non
j'étais concentré 1 pourquoi vous dites
ça non mais pourquoi vous dites sommes
pas une question que j'entends moi
j'entends parler dans les médias quand
je suis en train de livrer je regarde
des applications j'entends des trucs les
obligations sur les applications
alors tu apprendras par une application
et l'huile et les applications moi je
traîne dans les couloirs ça suffit au
ace combat va enquêter sur ba ba oui est
ce que tu es ce que vous voulez dire par
là isabelle les murs on est vrai je veux
dire par là que c'est un il se dit
beaucoup qu'une proposition vous avez
été faites qui était précisé que
finalement vous avez décliné mais
qu'elle était ferme alors je m'entends
très bien avec le groupe m6 vous savez
je le dirai toujours ce sont des hommes
et si un jour je dois quitter ses huit
sévère le groupe m6 que j'irai c'est sûr
et certain
chroniqueur pour avoir une question
subsidiaire à la question de raymond oui
qu'est la question suivante cdh aventure
nous habiller sur le groupe m6
est-ce que vous emmèneriez avec vous la
bande actuelle oui
[Applaudissements]
non pas tant le ya d'acteurs de mont
joli nom à deux trois noms près de trois
ans après voilà j'ai envie c est ce qu
actuellement votre merguez frétille non
ces jours ci en ce moment non ils
pensent que c'est une vraie merguez lee
pense grillades lui donc c'est le
directeur de mensonges et les basiques
moi je trouve qu'il n'a jamais aussi
bien marché ce bruit alors cyril avez
vous eu un rapport sexuel à moins de 72
heures vous fait remonter à entre samedi
11h30 et vivant
[Applaudissements]
je lui réponds non avait pas de libido
quoi disent ils pas des bruits va-t-il y
avoir une saison prochaine de tpm p
alors je vais vous dire oui
je vais vous dire pourquoi ça chez nous
que ça fait maintenant huit ans que sur
quotidienne plus deux ans de debdou est
en fait le record je crois que le record
pour un animateur de quotidienne en
direct ses 9 ans voilà donc l'année
prochaine
normalement on sera sur leur corps des
neuf ans donc voilà il n'y a pas que
pour ça et puis parce que franchement on
se régale en ce moment ça oui voilà et
que vous allez me manquer que vous allez
me manquer beaucoup ce week-end nous
savons tous que vous étiez marrakech
donc au maroc
quel pays préférés vous votre pays la
tunisie ou le maroc
je ne peux répondre par oui ou par non
j'ai dit ici j'ai réfléchi entre temps
non
a donc préféré la tunisie j'aime
beaucoup ma oui je ne peux pas rien
c'est comme si vous demandez un suédois
s'ils préfèrent le ce la suède ou la
norvège si les suédois est préféré à la
suède merci la dette grecque c'est vrai
oui s'il est ce qu'il vous arrive
d'envoyer régulièrement des messages
avec emmanuel macron le président la
république d'échangés intenses ont aussi
pesé changer quoi le chargé de discuter
de ce texte au nom
alors au moment de la communication on
est quand même à 75% de mensonges on
répondra sans avoir répondu à ma
question à part on l'a souvent lu dans
les journaux est ce que vous allez vous
présenter aux prochaines présidentielles
c'est vrai il paraît qu'on a parlé de
vous dans des conseils que je ne savais
oui je roule c'est un oui là on n'a rien
du tout gc oui je vous le dire c'est
qu'on s'est tous les maths en brassant
non
dit oui pour faire sauter les applis dit
oui diverses des zappings fait dire ou
[Musique]
es ce que vous avez eu des infos là
dessus sur quoi la fia s'il va se
présenter je sais quand même à parler à
l'assemblée au nom et à l'arrivée c'est
dire s'il a été cité plusieurs fois
l'assemblée nationale à s'emmerder for
once qui te revient fort et des choses
[Rires]
mais c'est quelque chose politique des
choses positives
certains donnent un peu marre de la
politique telle qu'elle est actuellement
donc on a envie de l'animateur populaire
qui pourrait être plus rassembleur alors
mais là j'ai juste dit oui pour le
zapping
alors la question à l'arrêt c'est dingue
parce que c'était quoi votre question
c'est est-ce qui vous est déjà arrivé et
en coupe d'avoir des pensées impures
pour une autre femme ruth et s'en va en
faire plus ça m'a vraiment c'est un
classique la réponse
soyons honnêtes crédibles et je la donne
frais en toute franchise en toute
franchise
les yeux dans les yeux
non pas impossible qu lagarde fait
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]